a very interesting new study finds that
Americans on average die younger in
conservative and red States now this
won't be a surprise to some of you who
know some of the underlying data here
but let's start with the study as
reported by the guardian more liberal
policies on environment gun safety labor
economic taxes and tobacco taxes
associated with lower mortality the
authors of the study write
simulations indicate that changing all
policy domains in all states to a fully
liberal orientation could have saved
over a hundred and seventy one thousand
lives in 2019 changing to a fully
conservative orientation could cost more
than two hundred and seventeen thousand
lives the study was published in plus
plus one plus one plos one I always
forget how it's pronounced which is a
science journal the authors are from
Syracuse Syracuse University Harvard VCU
University of Washington University of
Texas at Austin and University of
Western Ontario Canada
I have to tell you this really isn't
surprising there is a very interesting
metric and when we talk about the United
States sometimes it's said well the
United States could really be divvied up
into
six different regions that would be as
big as many European countries or 12
different regions I have seen there is a
metric called the human development
index this metric takes into account
health education income and life
expectancy to give us a number
essentially below zero and one one being
very high and zero being very low and
when you look around the world you see
maybe not like a hugely surprising list
of countries at the top of the list so
for example countries with a very very
high HDI human development index
Switzerland Norway Iceland Hong Kong
Australia no real surprises there
right there with them Denmark Sweden
Ireland Germany Netherlands Finland
Singapore Belgium New Zealand Canada you
start to see Trends in the types of
places that these are you can assign
values just like you can to a country to
a state and one of the things that you
will see which are totally separate from
this study that we're talking about here
is that the states with the highest hdis
also are overwhelmingly blue States
you've got at the top Massachusetts
Connecticut Minnesota New Jersey New
Hampshire Colorado DC North Dakota
Washington Hawaii New York Maryland
Vermont so we are
13 14 in
with one red State and one purple State
of New Hampshire
this is not new information to many of
us now what's an important question in
general is the life expectancy
specifically
do they die younger because they're
poorer and they're poorer due to
Republican economic policy or do they
die younger because of the direct effect
of Republican social and other policy
the answer pretty clearly seems to be a
sort of all of the above type of thing
uh going back to the article a little
bit
especially strong associations were
observed between certain domains and
specific causes of death between gun
safety and suicide mortality among men
between labor and alcohol-induced
mortality between both the economic tax
and tobacco tax and cardiovascular
mortality
um very very interesting and the study
authors also note that American life
expectancy as a whole is lower than most
high income countries falling between
Cuba and Albania
one of the things that sometimes will
come up on the show
is I want to move to a country with a
much higher standard of living
and one of the things to understand is
that a lot of times the folks saying
that are in states with low standards of
living it's difficult to move to a lot
of the countries on the list I showed
you but it's much easier relatively it's
not free there's still costs and
sometimes those states are more
expensive you can much more easily move
to a state in the U.S with an equivalent
standard of living too many of those
European countries because the United
States is so stratified and the
difference between Massachusetts and
Mississippi on every indicator could not
be more different so interesting study
not surprising information but
interesting to see it laid out so
cleanly in terms of the data we'll link
to the study so you can take a look at
it for yourselves I've had such trouble
finding a great razor where I am not
cutting myself or getting those Nicks on
my skin which are so common with the
cheap disposable razors you have to meet
our sponsor Henson shaving Henson
actually manufactures parts for the
International Space Station and the Mars
rover and they are bringing that exact
same Precision Engineering to the
Shaving experience it hurts when you
shave because blades extend too far and
thus they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and and it's awesome go to
hensonshaving.com Pacman add a razor and
a hundred pack of blades to your cart
then enter the code Pacman to get the
hundred blades for free that is a three
year Supply the link is down below